you know Saturday is the official start
of summer which also means it's prime
season for blockbuster movies concerts
and amusement parks so when will all
this stuff begin to open up well we've
got you covered
[Music]
it is not time yet to let our guard down
there's a high likelihood other people
in that park have Kovan 19 so you need
to consider every surface as infected
even though Koba 19 infections in
California are on the rise Disneyland a
celebrity go-to hangout is planning to
reopen July 17 doctor Travis Stork of
the doctor says guests must be extra
vigilant to decrease their risk of
infection extra precautions use a paper
towel to shut the water off use hand
sanitizer on top of that wearing a face
mask is so important in just keeping
that social distance as much as possible
advance reservations will be required
the park is expected to be at just 25
percent capacity
there will be no character
meet-and-greets or parades also expect
temperature checks and masks to be
required like we've seen at Universal
Studios Orlando which reopened June 5th
on June 4th at the stroke of midnight
Sin City began reopening its doors and
the crowds came out in full force it
feels unbelievable
masse are encouraged but not required
for guests in social videos posted
online many people have decided against
it this is still a time to be worried
about those around you the people who
will suffer are those who are older than
65 who have other illnesses that hasn't
changed
the residency's of artists like Lady
Gaga cher Shania Twain boys to men and
Keith Urban remain postponed but last
month Keith found a way to safely
perform for fans at a drive-in in
Nashville the bowling to people in cars
it's the most obvious natural way of
distancing everybody June 27th Garth
Brooks will perform in Nashville the
concert will not have an audience but it
will be live streamed to 300 drive-in
theaters across North America other
artists may follow suit I'm ready to go
to the drive-in again I'm ready but
there won't be any Beyonce sighs
Coachella headliners this year the 125
thousand capacity festival is officially
canceled so is stagecoach and the
Lollapalooza festival but what about
movie theaters this summer party on
dudes California has been given the
green light to open however LA does not
meet the requirements and will remain
shut I do believe we need to try to get
people back out and about engaging in
life the important thing is if you have
good ventilation and you have some space
between people then things can resume
much more safely
what I've seen too much try and keep up
as of right now Robert Pattinson is
highly anticipated drama tenant move on
and Bill and Ted face the music are all
still scheduled for release dates in
July and August f9 the next film in the
Fast and Furious franchise was supposed
to premiere in May but has been pushed
to April 20-21 co-star Ludacris told me
no matter what fans will be able to
watch we're all seeing a lot of changes
with films coming straight to video on
demands the team at Universal is going
to make sure that they get this movie to
the fans directly one way or another
[Music]